hey youtubers it's Charlie this week on
Legend of Korra we totally got to see
two old friends from avatar last
airbender maybe one of them wasn't quite
so much of a friend we also got to see
some serious else in Wonderland
references une lock blackmailed Korra
into helping him and harmonic
convergence is upon us so first I'll do
my favorite moments and then I'll do my
review everybody grab some tea where's
my tea so first off right away how
awesome was it to see IRA again it made
me really sad to think about how Mako is
dead but the Alice in Wonderland
references were actually pretty neat you
know Korra basically getting sucked into
all these portals until she finally
ended up in the forest
obviously the parable aspect of the
episode was pretty heavy-handed it was
just meant to teach Korra that giving
off bad vibes in the spirit world
basically turns regular spirits into
evil spirits so I'm guessing that that
means that whenever she fights against
vaatu she's going to have to give off
some sort of nuclear mega good vibe I do
have a few complaints about baby Korra
but I'll talk about that during my
review my number two favorite thing
obviously was watching Tom's library
it's more of a tree house library at
this point and upside-down tree house
library but it was still really fun to
see it again they didn't use him in a
really big way and I was really
surprised to see him double-cross Jinora
like that but when he said unlock is a
true friend of the spirits I think he
kind of gave away a little bit of the
plot I think that vaatu is just trying
to take over the normal realm and the
spirit realm so the spirits would just
pass back into the normal realm but they
were during wands time it's so
unfortunate that he is so grossly
misinformed about little tiny men and
radios but overall the visual look of
the spirit world was really interesting
let's take a quick poll who liked the
spirit world the way it was depicted
more during Aang's time and who liked
the spirit world now there were a few
complaints that the spirit world just
seemed too bright and shiny but I think
that's just a consequence of the
animation studio changing just a little
bit obviously the studio mirrors back
but Legend of Korra has a very different
animation style than avatar last
airbender had I do love the 3d animation
effects that they have in the episode it
kind of gives the camera this panning
effect especially like when Jinora was
reading from the book but high five
yourself if you guess that unalaq was
gonna use Jinora - blackmail Korra I
think a lot of people kind of assume
this because otherwise how is he going
to get that portal open it's not like
Korra was gonna do it for him and based
on the fact that we knew the title of
one of the next episodes is going to be
harmonic convergence I think we could
just assume that it was going to happen
anyway we're actually in that period
when we really only have two more weeks
of Legend of Korra but both of those
weeks are going to be hour-long episodes
be sure to
subscribe to get my videos because next
week we're gonna see harmonic
convergence and the is on but what
did I think of the episode overall well
I give it a solid beep mostly just
because it was so awesome seeing Iroh
and washi Tong again but I was not a
huge fan of baby Korra like I said it
was basically just a parable just to
teach Korra the value of giving off
positive vibes in the spirit world or
the consequence of giving negative vibes
off
I feel like IRA could have just
explained it to her with about two
sentences and we the audience and Korra
would have totally understood they've
actually been a couple of episodes this
season where it felt like there was
maybe like two or three minutes of
actual plot development and like
eighteen minutes of filler but like I
said we're in the last couple of weeks
so it's basically just gonna barrel down
the plot but I think that will answer a
lot of concerns about story progression
so next week the first episode will be
night of a thousand stars than the
second episode will be harmonic
convergence then the week after that
will be the two-part finale if there's
anything I didn't mention in the video
that you thought was really important in
the episode be sure to write it in the
comments and we'll discuss if I as
always if you really want to help me out
please like and share this video on
social big news tomorrow I'll be posting
a video for the Doctor Who 50th
anniversary trailers airing I'll
probably post that video around 1 or 2
o'clock p.m. Pacific time right now
click here to learn more about legend
accorded this season and click here to
learn all about the Doctor Who 50th
anniversary episode thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives